PLAYOFF PG13 STANDING BY WITH
REBECCA HAARLOW.
>> Rebecca: THANKS, IAN.
WHAT AN INCREDIBLY HARD-FOUGHT
GAME, THIS JAZZ TEAM WOULDN'T GO
AWAY, HAD YOU SIX DIFFERENT
PLAYERS IN DOUBLE FIGURES, CAN
YOU DESCRIBE THE RESILIENCY YOUR
SQUAD SHOWED PLAYING WITHOUT
KAWHI LEONARD TONIGHT.
>> YEAH, THIS WAS -- I THOUGHT
THIS WAS OUR TOUGHEST MATCH UP
THIS POST-SEASON.
THIS IS THE BIGGEST GAME OF OUR
SEASON, ESPECIALLY BEING DOWN
OUR BEST PLAYER.
WE WISH QUIET BEST
WE WISH KAWHI, THE BEST AND A
SPEEDY RECOVER WHY.
WE KNEW COMING INTO THIS WE HAD
TO PLAY TOGETHER AND STEP UP.
I THOUGHT EVERYBODY PLAYED THEIR
ROLES COLLECTIVELY AND WE
LIMITED OUR TURNOVERS.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT WAS KEY
TONIGHT.
>> Rebecca: WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
FIRST HALF THEY SHOT LIGHTS OUT
AND IN THE SECOND HALF YOU HELD
THEM TO JUST THREE MADE THREES
IN THE ENTIRE SECOND HALF.
DEFENSIVELY WHAT WAS THE KEY
THERE?
>> JUST STAYED WITH IT.
I THOUGHT A LOT OF THEIR THREES
WERE TOUGH, WE DIDN'T OVERREACT.
THEY CAME OUT HOT, GOOD THING WE
WAS ABLE TO WEATHER THE STORM,
WE ATTACKED ON OFFENSE AS WELL.
WE TOOK THEIR BLOWS, WE TOOK
THEIR PUNCHES.
THEY JUST COULDN'T SUSTAIN US
OVER FULL 48 GAME.
>> WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE SERIES,
YOU GO UP 3-2, HEADING HOME, ONE
GAME AWAY FROM HEADING TO THE
WESTERN CONFERENCE FINALS,
WHAT'S IT GOING TO TAKE TO CLOSE
THIS THING OUT AT HOME?
>> PUT THIS ONE BEHIND US.
GET READY FOR A ROCKING CROWD
BACK IN L.A..
UNBELIEVABLE OPPORTUNITY WE GOT
WAITING FOR US BACK HOME.
WE JUST GOT TO GO INTO THE
MINDSET THAT